herr rentmeister eine kurze frage noch
zu der bediensteten wie geht es der dame
jetzt das wichtigste ist dass sie den
einsatz zumindest äußerlich körperlich
unverletzt überstanden hat dass eine
solche tat eine solche bedrohung durch
einen täter schwer wie eine psychische
folgen nach sich ziehen kann versteht
jeder dass ist auch klar
und deshalb ist eine betreuung derzeit
ganz wichtig können sie uns nach eben
zwei sachen sagen wenn er diesen
polizeihubschrauber gefordert hatte gab
es irgendwelche zeit ultimaten hat gab
es eine verhandlungsgruppe die versucht
hat positiv auf den mann einzuwirken wie
müssen wir uns das vorstellen wie das da
passiert ist
ich kann natürlich aus den gründen das
ermittlungsverfahren ist noch nicht
genau sagen wie die abläufe waren das
wäre jetzt auch zu früh das musste auch
die staatsanwaltschaft bewerten die
forderung nach dem polizeihubschrauber
das wird natürlich nicht das motiv der
tat gewesen sein damit wollte sich der
täter offenbar die flucht ermöglichen
ob und welche zeitraum werde vorgegeben
hat das weiß ich nicht
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei beschaulich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren